another major defeat for the anti-woke
clowns this time it is that drag ban
ruled unconstitutional
this is the beautiful detail Folks by a
trump appointed judge the Tennessee
anti-drag Bill violates free speech and
expression it's too broad and too vague
the Associated Press has a great report
on this Tennessee's first in the nation
law designed to place strict limits on
drag shows is unconstitutional a federal
judge says the law is both quote
unconstitutionally vague and
substantially overbroad and encourages
discriminatory enforcement according to
the ruling late Friday by U.S District
Judge Thomas Parker appointed by failed
former president Donald Trump quote
there is no question that obscenity is
not protected by the First Amendment but
there's a difference between material
that is obscene in the vernacular and
material that is obscene under the law
simply put no majority of the Supreme
Court has held that sexually explicit
but not obscene speech receives less
protection than political artistic or
scientific scientific speech said the
judge the article also says the law
would have banned adult Cabaret
performances from public property or
anywhere miners might be present
performers who broke the law risked
being charged with a misdemeanor or a
felony for a repeat offense this is a
Bonkers law it deserved to be taken down
and so far that is the decision now will
it be appealed we will see but we knew
you know it it's funny it's important to
let legal Scholars and jurists weigh in
on these things but we could all see
that the use of the word obscenity was
being used not as it is required to be
used under the law but just colloquially
oh that's obscene I don't know I see a
picture of a drag performer that's
obscene and that's my opinion that's not
legally obscene and that's actually what
matters here and good for the Trump
appointed judge for pointing that out
the bill is vague it's broad it doesn't
really Define what is an adult Cabaret
performance what is a male impersonator
it leaves room for arbitrary enforcement
discriminatory enforcement but the most
important thing is listen the first
obstacle is let's get a legal opinion
that shows the nuts and bolts of this
Tennessee anti-drag Bill are ridiculous
that's step one
step two let's remember that it is again
being pushed by Hypocrites Tennessee
governor Bill Lee who previously dressed
in drag now says this is a danger to our
children and this is the law we need so
they are hypocrites legally problematic
hypocritical but the zoom out the thirty
thousand foot
is that this one bill is just a part of
the larger wave of the anti-lgbt
legislation that we're seeing in many
right-wing States it's targeting trans
youth it's Banning gender affirming care
it's limiting access to bathrooms it's
doing all sorts of different things and
it's all motivated by the rights saying
now it is trans people who are the
scapegoats for a long time it was gay
men maybe for like a week it was
lesbians they never really were too
worked up about lesbians for a while it
was gay men and now they're shifting
over to saying the problem is trans
people and it's motivated by fear it's
motivated by misinformation it depends
on stereotypes and myths about remember
the first it was The Stereotype and myth
of the gay man as the pedophile
didn't make any sense but gay men are
interested in other gay men who have
gone through puberty we're not talking
about pedophilia now they're applying
that to trans people uh people are going
to say oh I put on a wig and now I'm a
woman so I can hit on little girls in a
bathroom that's already illegal doesn't
matter which bathroom you're in already
against the law don't need any new laws
to prevent that and it also essentially
never happens and
um they're now targeting drag shows to
completely benign we interviewed a drag
performer a few weeks ago who was very
articulately able to explain the
absurdity of all of this so the Hope
here is that if this decision is
appealed it will be upheld uh not that
the bill will be upheld that the
unconstitutionality of banning drag
shows will be upheld and this is again
another one of these issues where the
right now is saying look at all of these
leftists wanting to die on the hill of
drag shows we're not the ones who
started this thing we're just saying the
law should be enforced and the Bills
should be the laws should be evaluated
for their constitutionality it is
because of the right making this an
issue that this is an issue left Wingers
weren't going around saying let's go
around creating uh defenses for drag
shows and for as long as the right keeps
pushing these nonsense laws My Hope Is
um that the left and sane thinking
jurists are going to do what needs to be
done to point out that the laws are not
only hypocritical capricious and
unnecessary uh but also unconstitutional
in the way that this one is let's take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show we are powering
towards
1.75 million YouTube subscribers which
will put us within that final 250
000 subscriber push to 2 million be a
part of it we'll take a quick break and
be right back